how Twitter can help you get a job so I
got a question from one of my Twitter
followers Stephanie who wrote in to say
at me can you do a video explaining how
I can use Twitter to help me land the
job after the job interview has been
done and this is a great question kind
of a unique question I don't really get
asked too much about jobs because I
focus on entrepreneurial stuff but I'm
always happy to give it my best shot so
I'm gonna I'm gonna imagine now that I'm
an employee trying to get a job at a
company anyway I'm just joking I'm just
joking
it's a great question so how do we do it
first of all understand that with most
jobs employees potential employees do a
terrible job of showing their passion
for the job that they're trying to get
into and they just do the bare minimum
most of the people who I've had
interview for positions that I've had
they don't even read the Job Description
properly they don't know anything about
my company they show zero effort zero
initiative and so they're obviously not
gonna get to the next step the point
here is that a lot of people a lot of
the candidates people you're going up
against are not showing any initiative
so just showing a little bit of
initiative already puts you ahead of
most of the other people how to use our
initiatives to get the job and how can
you use Twitter to help you what I would
do is I would use Twitter to show one
that not only you understand the company
that you're trying to get into but two
that you believe the same things they
believe in and you help promote one of
their campaigns by you asking this
question I'm assuming that your new job
has something to do with Twitter or
social media marketing somehow you know
if it doesn't and then they may not care
about what you do on Twitter but if you
do then you have a shot I would try to
look at one thing that they're doing
really well and make this something
important like what does this company do
that you love one project that they're
working on that really speaks to your
heart that gets you excited - yeah I
love this company I really want to go
work for them and then create a tweet
that highlights that project and copies
them in on it use their handle and your
goal with this tweet is not just sucking
up and showing you know that that you're
highlighting them in one of the projects
I mean that helped us already more than
then probably any other candidate that
you're going up against it's gonna do
already more but what I'd love for you
to do is then try to promote that what I
want you to do is get that tweet to be
retweeted by as many people as you can
so you have to leave enough room for
people to have retweet and your full
name in and that company's full name in
as well as your tweet I know it's hard
but this is your challenge what I want
to have happen is for that company to
look on Twitter and see their name and
your name being mentioned by a lot of
people and highlighting a project that
they care about and you care about if
you can do that and and it may just be
you telling all your friends hey can you
please retweet this right like you may
not have a huge following yourself
that's okay
it could be telling everybody you know
old high school friends whatever it is
please I'm trying to get a job with this
company just retweet this message if you
can get lots of people retweeting this
they have to pay attention to you and
they say Stephanie is standing out
against everybody else and she's taking
so much initiative to help us here's an
example of how this has worked for me
I've never applied for a job especially
with Twitter but recently got into a
fight with a local company was a
hamburger restaurant they only accepted
cash at their building and I hate paying
just cash because I can't track it and I
have to carry coins I just I hate paying
cash so I tweeted like you guys got to
get you know take debit take credit and
so worth the 2% fee or whatever it is
anyway the owner was upset he called me
out on Twitter he told all his followers
to start hating on me he was being a
huge little man and as a result I spent
the whole night fighting and responding
to all of his followers on Twitter one
of them called in hero burger which is
another local hamburger store and saying
well our place is way better than Huber
don't go we didn't hear a burger
whatever why don't you go you to hear a
burger because you don't like our
hamburgers finally and that created this
whole threat that copied me and hero
burger and the company that I was
fighting with and lots of people said it
responded and copied hero burger in on
it later on in that night hero burger
respond and say hey guys why can't we
all get along and then they sent me a
private message and it was their
director of marketing who wanted to talk
with me to see if there's anything that
we could do together he wanted to learn
more about what I was up to and once if
there's a way to work together on a
project and that all happened because of
Twitter now I could have probably gotten
the job with your burger if I wanted to
in some kind of marketing capacity or
social media but because they kept
getting called out on Twitter with their
handle name and my handle name by a lot
of people it forced them to pay
attention it forced them to respond and
take action so that's what I want to
have happen for you I want this company
to see their name
Stephanie's name and the message being
mentioned by a lot of people so that
they are forced to respond to take
notice to say this girl Stephanie
what was she applying for again who is
she how do we get her on our team
that's what I would do believe was he
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below let me know what you think
leave a comment underneath you have a
question for me leave it below if you
ever use Twitter to help you land a job
or guess the sales capacity of somehow
leave it below I want to hear your story
and subscribe to the channel if you
wanna see more videos thank you so much
and I'll see you soon